Liberty Township Ohio I am headed your
way Friday February 16th and Saturday
February 17th Winnipeg my first time
headed your way I'll be there Friday
March 1st and Saturday March 2nd Omaha
we're going to do it this time I promise
you last time we got our flights
cancelled this time we're taking a
straight shot I'll be there Friday March
29th and Saturday March 30th Columbus
Ohio I'm fired up to head your way never
been there in my first time coming to
your beautiful city I'll be there Friday
April 12th and Saturday April 13th Los
Angeles I'm excited to announce that I'm
part of the Netflix is a joke Festival I
have my own show Sunday May 12th at The
Bourbon Room you guys ask me how come
you're not on Netflix well here's a
chance to sell this thing out and show
them why I should be get your tickets
now don't wait all tickets available at
Ryan sickler
[Music]
docomo with Ryan
[Applause]
zler welcome back to the Honeydew y'all
we're over here in the night pant
Studios doing it up today y'all I'm Ryan
sickler Ryan sickler docomond on all
your social media and I want to thank
you I want to thank every single one of
you whether you've been here or whether
you're new here whether you go back to
the feast wherever you come from however
you got here ymh all of it thank you
very much please subscribe to this
channel help us out and if you got to
have more please check out that patreon
it's the Honeydew with y'all it is this
show with y'all and I'm telling you for
five bucks a month all right you will
never find the stories that you're going
to hear on this show it is wild wild
stories fun stuff crazy stuff for five
bucks a month you're getting hundreds of
episodes all right and if you're looking
for a new podcast to listen to go listen
to my old podcast the crab Feast that
I'm telling you that Community is still
so alive and well I love seeing the
feaster at the show um it's going to do
over a million downloads I say that one
year at this Library it's been it's been
gone for five years and today's guest
had two fantastic episodes you got to go
listen to all right that's the biz now
you guys know what we're doing over here
we're highlighting the low lights I
always say the these are the stories
behind the storytellers and I am very
excited to have this guest here today
for the first time on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Hunter Hill everybody Welcome to the
Honey Hill feels good to be here dude
first of all thank you for being here
I've said to you outside before you're
somebody I'll always say yes to you've
been nothing but good to me kind to me
from day one um it's been a pleasure to
watch you grow um I know you go out and
work with Eliza you work with Taylor
Tomlinson like you're you're legit bro
so before we get into your stories and
again I'm telling you his crab Fe
stories are absolutely worth the listen
um please plug promote everything and
anything Hunter Hill hi uh I'm out on
the road I'm headlining clubs around the
country right now you guys can see me in
Chicago Boston Portland Maine San Diego
Phoenix uh Seattle Portland Oregon all
of it is at hunterhill comedy.com and
hunterhill comedy on Instagram boom yeah
dude well it's been it's been a few
years since I've seen you and the last I
saw you were not a dad you're a dad now
and I always ask people to send stuff in
so you know I want to hear about first
of all how old's your son my son he'll
be two in December all right so okay
he's he's entered toddlerhood he's a
ball of energy he's the best thing about
my life hands down but also my
definition of Love patience and tired
change on a daily basis don't they yeah
I feel like the GRE remember when they
were little you're like I'll never raise
my voice at this thing oh my God you're
like
stop just counting to three as calmly as
I can yeah I just say to I'll say out
loud front number two like God please
let me hold it back I do that all the
time too I try to make her laugh about
it instead of like get angry about it
but man it's the best thing I'll ever do
uh we were just talking outside about
like it's family first and you got to
figure out how to include comedy into
family not family into comedy absolutely
it's got to be that way yeah I feel like
I'm an airplane trying to get off the
ground and my Runway just like like I'm
trying to figure out the line between
chasing a dream and being delusional
that's what I'm trying to do but I I
think i' I think I'm doing a good job
being delusional is beautiful yeah yeah
it just means your brain works different
but then when it happens who was
delusional the people that told you you
couldn't do it or you absolutely yeah
all you got to do is make yourself happy
happy all you got to do is believe in
you and all you got to do with your
family and [__] is make it whatever
works best for you you know what I mean
like there are people like I've had to
take my daughter to the comedy club
before I don't have anybody to watch her
so she sits in the green room and I'm
like put headphones on and watch your
tablet you know what I'm saying like
I've had to do that I've had to what am
I going to do sometimes you got to bring
your kid to work this happens to be our
work it is wild how other parents move
their weight to and get judgmental when
like sure there's some bad parents out
there but at the end of the day like Hey
we're all just trying our [__] best
and it is there isn't one person out
there I'm talking to everybody that has
kids there's not one person out there
that doesn't have room for improvement
as a parent not one no one's bad in 100
not one no no they they might be hiding
behind like an adderal prescription or
or or or reading to some good book you
know listen to some good books on tape
but but no one's bad in 100 no one's no
one's got it figured out also idiots
have been doing this for years so why
why are we being so hard we feel like
we're no you guys this it's like you all
know this has been going on for
gazillion years right forever forever
it's uh it's a lot man I'm uh I love
being a dad I think being a standup is
kind of the best job in the world
because I can be a stay-at-home dad
during the week and play Rockstar on the
weekends it's uh kind of like a a Hannah
Montana grind that I'm on right now
living that Best of Both Worlds so in
the First on not even two years yet you
already have a scare where you had to go
to the ER with your son yeah we're we're
we're we're good parents I
don't if it starts like that I don't I
don't know if my wife I don't know if I
should have gave nine hot dogs but we're
good parents it's it's you know my wife
probably wouldn't want me talking about
this we were responsible you know we
went to every class that the hospital
has before you have the kiddo and it's
like CPR don't shake the baby the
breathing exercises all the [__] in the
crib that's got to get out don't put the
mesh in they could roll up and choke on
everything is trying to kill you we went
to all of those classes no one ever told
us that this could happen we were at we
we we live in Burbank we've got a
community pool that has like a little
toddler section and we were hanging out
with uh some some other parent friends
that we've made through a gymnastics
class and Mercer was eating this uh not
trail mix cuz it you know yeah we we'll
say trail mix but like crunched up super
tiny
nothing chokable and I had taken him
away from his mom so that she could take
a phone call at one point and he did one
of those like inhale cries you know like
where you just like you you know it's
going to be big and no one ever told us
this could happen but when he inhal
cried he he didn't choke every all the
food just surpassed his throat and went
directly into his lungs oh [__] I didn't
know this could happen no idea so you're
saying that in the food he's chewing and
if a baby that age can breathe it in it
goes right it doesn't go to the stomach
it goes in the lungs do not pass go do
not collect $200 the lungs the lungs and
and my wife and I play different roles I
think my my role is already just like I
don't want to make this kid's life too
easy and hers is you know everything's
wrong all the time we need to go get it
checked out and and we meet in the
middle we balance each other out we were
at the pool one of the other dads was a
firefighter
he didn't seem too alarmed he's like
you're always going to know what's best
for your kid was was the advice we were
being given one of the other moms was an
ICU nurse and they were just like yeah
he's probably just got something you
know stuck in his throat it'll go away
and my wife was just like no we're going
home we're going home and while we're
driving home I'm like why don't we just
go to our pediatrician's office why
don't we just pop in see if we can do
that and we go there and the
pediatrician's like should have gone
straight to the hospital and our
pediatrician told us not to go to
specific hospitals she's she's like
don't go to St Mary yeah she's like you
guys live near St Joseph do not waste
your time with St Joseph she's she she
like explicitly was like throwing
hospitals under the bus she's like you
shouldn't be here you need go to the
hospital don't don't go to this hospital
that will not end well so we went but
wait so what is it that she
noticed just per experience she's like
no that your child has food in the like
that's where you find out what's wrong
or you don't know yet what is really
going on we she was like what I think
has happened is I think something is
blocking the lungs can we do that as
adults I don't know and now I'm
terrified I also don't
know I don't know if I'll ever feel
anything deeply enough to
go Bo maybe like a kick Gasper I'm a
Gasper though I don't know I drop [__] I
go and I better be careful
end just I I'm going to need something
like my lungs already took a beat and I
can't have food in them they're clot
free for Christ's sake I haven't lost a
parent yet but I will be sure not to be
snacking while while moving through that
all right that's good to know and uh she
sent us to the hospital man and and that
I've I've had some scary days in my life
that was that was wild cuz I I've worked
on and we've both worked on television
sets we we've you know been in
situations where you can see people
acting calmly when everything is going
wrong and and thank God our doctor sent
us she sent us to Children's Hospital
Los Angeles and they were spectacular I
mean we walked in they they just had a
held a stethoscope up to my son's chest
didn't even fill out paperwork wasn't
even like where's an insurance card it
was just like let's get you back like
they heard it yeah they were just like
okay and then they've got him on a
machine for doctors are now like in the
room they're bringing them books they're
bringing them toys so he's in good
spirits still that's the thing that's
why the dad and me was like yeah I think
he's okay like he seems okay cuz he was
like laughing he was if I made a face
always look at that energy too I'm like
energy level seems good but this is okay
and and it turns out it was good cuz
there was so little oxygen in him that
he was getting a little loopy he's
tripping he's just tripping man and and
I'm like he he he seems chill and my
wife's like no he's too chill um this
poor kid is tripping that happens I can
only make these jokes because it's the
only way I can approach these insanely
dark scenarios this is what the show is
well we are scared I mean they are they
telling you anything that are they
saying hey this could be bad they're
telling us in in the calmest they're
telling us everything's bad but making
it sound like everything's going to be
fine cuz they're a children's hospital
right which to me is like I understand
what you're saying and you know they're
saying there you know it looks like we
might have to go in and uh you know use
like a claw mechanism to to take out the
particles and my wife's still thinking
like sounds like okay so maybe you know
we won't need to do that and I was like
no that's you know they're not wasting
their time with like all of the
hypotheticals of what's going to happen
and I've just never been I've never felt
that helpless before just just uh it's a
weird thing becoming a parent and and
I've noticed this in making trying to
make friendships with other parents is
it's weird walking into a conversation
with somebody where the other person
already knows the easiest way to hurt
you just like hey everything I I love
and care about the just something that
would destroy me is right here yeah and
and the only reason I think it's easy to
make parent friends in like these class
scenarios is because it's like yeah yeah
my my biggest weakness is right here and
I I have never felt that before I've
lived through a lot I've gotten numb to
a lot and this was the first time we
were just like not crying when he was in
the room cuz you're just like you know
I'm taking him in for chest x-rays
telling them we're just going to get a
big picture you know and and and just
talking him through it and the whole
time doctor's like just on the other
side of the door in case something like
crashes cuz the the blood oxygen level
was just like so he if he collapses
literally yeah just scary low like we
just are we gonna have to revive this
kid at any minute and uh Jesus yeah and
then you've got you've got doctors and
their egos that you like everyone on the
the ground floor was great and then once
you got up to like the surgeon level
that's when like those God egos come in
and then you're like okay I I I like
some of you and that that one specific
dude who's winking at me can just get
the [__] out yeah like why are you
flirting with me right now it's it's it
it it gets dark quick I let my son watch
a screen for the first time while we
were pushing away on a gurnie just cuz I
didn't want him to go out without
watching incanto it it it is just like
so dark and so real and and I mean uh
yeah just just being held in that
suspense for hours they're taking him
into a uh room now to to remove the food
yeah they and are you allowed in there
no CU this is this still during like Co
to or a little after this is very recent
this is this is like a month ago Jesus
dude yeah man wow okay this is you know
that they're not worried about Co
anymore um and it it went through they
they gave him an oxygen treatment to see
if it wasn't food like if we put this
chemical in there is it going to open
his lungs up enough that didn't work and
then right away they're like it looks
like we're need to have surgery they had
him in surgery like so he's in there and
you guys aren't allowed in that room at
all not at all we how long is he in
there an hour and a half 2 hours and you
guys are just sitting in the waiting
room we thank God we we live in LA and
the hospital had a farmers market that
day so we were just walking around this
farmers market uh you know looking at
different types of uh are you just
[__] I'm soing crying and looking at
kale and
Shing I'm in like a cafeteria bananas
look amazing oh and we're in La I'm just
in a cafeteria sponsored by Dreamworks
just just crying in front of every Kung
Fu Panda cartoon
that's blood at Children's Hospital so I
know what it looks like yeah a Chadwick
Boseman like black panther mural and
you're just like no
dead it's terrible you're just you're
going oh my God I just oh oh man dude
I've lost family members and I haven't
cried and and and this was holding me in
this yeah I mean this is also a helpless
little child that like doesn't even know
pure innocence doesn't even know what
he's going in for right now doesn't even
know something's wrong with him yeah
he's [__] feeling great man he's
tripping his balls off to this day he'll
never know that he's gone under for a
Sur descending balls off he's doing
okay he's having a good goddamn time
here just a good heady Sunday man okay
so they take him in so he's in there an
hour and a half and do they come and get
you do they how do they notify you hey
this is done they they kind of give you
this tiny DMV waiting room where they
call numbers and they're like you're
you're your kid is ready your kid is
ready but you have to just sit either in
this tiny room for two hours or feel
confident enough to like go on a walk
for 30 minutes can I ask you this if
you're comfortable answering this
because I know what children's hospital
is All About Steve Simone is you know
been a big uh influence on me in
donating blood there and helping kids
out and things and
um you're in there with other parents
who are getting not good news yeah
you're in there with other parents who
are getting the worst news so you know
it's always been a thing for me like
you're getting good news thank goodness
um and you got to sort of keep that in
check too I feel like respectfully in
front of people who aren't getting good
news because you're all there and and
it's you you said it might be the size
of this room it is it is palpable like
every every step of the way um this was
July 3rd we went in um so day before
Fourth of July and and we weren't sure
what side of that we were going to fall
on you know and and we would be in rooms
with kids who were like laughing and
like just maybe needed like an x-ray or
something like that that wasn't that
serious and it's thank God I
guess thank goodness that the kids are
there because you have to keep your [__]
together for them and and I am in no
position to be mad at another family for
being happy that their kid isn't in my
spot or you know vice versa but it is
yeah man it's it's weird being in that
room
just just feeling so vulnerable I think
I'm Invincible all the time and and then
just this thing just checked me in in
the biggest way and than thank God he's
okay but so tell me about they tell you
your son's uh ready to be seen and you
go back in this room is he all tubed up
and all that stuff yeah he had an oxygen
math mask on he you know is he awake or
is he sort of coming out of it he was
still kind of coming out of it but he
was able to like hold you know hold my
hand like this and I'm just still crying
Weir we my wife and I weren't both
allowed back to be with him at once so
then it's like uh I I I have to let her
go first cuz cuz that's the rule mom mom
always goes first but then I'm just in
this Lobby like okay she's taking her
time and like I would also like it was
it was weird man it was uh just awful
awful awful awful and and everyone that
works at that hospital is amazing they
do such an incredible job and and I know
Steve I've also just seen CL like Jimmy
Kimmel will like stop an episode just to
celebrate this Hospital we're so lucky
that we live so close to a hospital like
this um and even with and also I don't
mean to interrupt but like the doctor
told you if you go to the other place
this you might not be having this result
isn't that wild it is it is wild to also
in close Pro it's it's a few miles apart
15minute drive you all can't communicate
with one another how to do the right
this the right way over there the
difference could be life or death yes
and or or you know smooth pregnancy bad
it is wild how what happened to in the
hospital in the in the beginning of the
year when I clouded they told me that if
like where we had our baby they said
it's great hospital to have a child you
have this there you're you're done wow
like we have what you need here and I'm
like you guys are right down the [__]
Street like it doesn't make sense to me
that part and and I'm with you cuz I I
you know it's all I guess it's all what
do you call it perspective because I
have to go still have to go to an
oncologist to be checked out and I sit
in this room and the last time I was
there I was over an hour and you know I
part of me wants to be like what the
[__] you know and then when they call me
I walk past all of these people getting
chemo and I'm like you know what I could
sit and wait another [__] hour what
what am I like I it's it's a shame that
it took that for me to calm down and and
put things in perspective but I'm proud
of myself that I don't know the
18-year-old me have been even looked
over there I took the time to see it and
I was like oh [__] you know what that
hour that I just spent there was no
chemo going in my body I can sit here
and chill for an hour they're clearly
[__]
busy and and you know I then I just shut
the [__] up and and chilled out on it
this is a a weird uh thing to come out
of that but I I my wife and I lived
through uh a Mudslide which I talked
about on another one of your podcast
story of CB Feast is incredible it was
it was yeah I thought that was the
scariest day of my life and then the
kiddo in the hospital much scarier but I
remember after the mudslide the the 101
freeway was still underwater for like a
a month I think and they were finally
able to dig these train tracks clear so
that the train could could get people
out and I got on the first train out of
Santa Barbara let's talk about it okay
where where you want start start at the
beginning so you're well first of all
all thank God your son's okay yeah
kiddo's okay and um you're right this
story is something I'll never forget um
so there was Northern California
mudslides you were up there for with
your wife's family at the time or yeah
we were we were going to what year was
this again when this happened this would
have been 2018 okay um we were going to
celebrate her little sister's 14th
birthday um little sister was about to
turn 14 and we just for context we
ignored a mandatory evacuation to avoid
the mudslide
because that doesn't really sound like
something that's going to happen in your
backyard doesn't sound like something
that's going to happen in Santa Barbara
or mono and we had all just been
evacuated like four or five times from
the Thomas fires right before that so we
a little fatigued you know over the
whole hey yeah you you you left your
house all four or five of those times
nothing happened now they're like like
there's going to be a mud slide you're
like well that's when does that ever
happen you know we're going to hang
tight and and the law enforcement that
came by the house were like that that
was kind of their reaction as well like
yeah we get it but we have to come by
and you know check you out so we we went
to sleep that night and we woke up at
3:00 in the morning to this gas line
explosion at the house behind us so this
gas pipe that used to be 40 feet
underground was now 75 feet above ground
just a flame pumping just just yeah it
was this house the only way I could
describe the kind of explosion that it
would look like is the White House in
Independence Day this thing just just
gone just were there people in it I I
can't remember if that specific house
had people in it I I know we kind of
bumped shoulders with people who lived
in the house next to it and and they had
burn wounds and and you know their house
even you feel that like is that what
wakes you up as like the explosion the
the rock of that you know what's
embarrassing is uh I snore so I woke up
to my wife shaking me awake dude you SLE
through slept through an I slept through
a Mudslide I slept through an explosion
I get the [__] out of here you slept
through that dud I slept through it and
this wasn't it was a big over 350 homes
were destroyed 90% of the people that
died on that day were on the the street
behind us so we were 150 ft away from
not waking up again and and I wake up to
my wife just shaking me um uh you know
my my I I don't sleep with clothes on so
I'm I'm like disheveled and like just
naked like look uh trying to figure my
[__] out my mother-in-law is running in
I'm just like just helicopter [__] at
her just trying to figure out what to do
I'm trying to find cats cuz we have cats
I'm throwing Furniture just trying
trying to get them that's when you
realize how great a dog is the fact that
I could just been in a disaster and just
just been like come here boy yeah just
call your dog yeah good boy let's go um
yeah and and we and it was wild we you
know ran outside you're looking at this
this 550 foot flame it's 3:00 at night
sky is lit orange like it could have
been and was the explosion CA of the
mudslide yeah because of the land shift
that's what opened up these gas lines
got it and it was
like wild I mean I I our her uncle was
with us and he had his phone out and I'm
just like that's wild and her
grandparents were there it was this
really weird moment cuz I was her dad
and I were in like a not a great place
like I I was asking for permission and
and there wasn't like a a clear yes or
no he didn't give you like a resounding
yeah it not right out the gates at first
it was like well regardless of what I
think you mean a lot to her and and
regardless of what I think you mean a
lot that's not how this goes of what I
think let's try that again
uh I'm not I'm not like I'm not a sturd
you know it's just not my time to shine
I'm not like a like my whole life
everyone's like you should be a lineman
and I'm like I want to be a sturdy
thespian and just like in this natural
disaster
and uh yeah we throwing people into cars
it was like driving through and what's
happening is it moving through like like
water like like that fluid you know what
I mean powerful yeah it was our driveway
or her parents driveway was a river like
you could not see the bottom of it like
us getting in our cars mud just mud just
just and flowing and I I is it pulling
cars too and is like you yeah once we
got once we got out of the driveway you
know we we it was kind of how the hell
are you even
driving the scariest thing I've ever
like before the hospital stuff was just
putting the car in Drive anytime I had
to take the car from Park to drive was
just this you're safe right now you
could stay here you could just sit right
here and not you know see what happens
or you can put the car and drive and and
see what's going to happen down the road
and we made turns where houses were
passing us it's it's like houses it's
like Des Ding A Dream you know it's like
we were in your neighborhood but it
wasn't your neighborhood it was like
being in the Tornado from Wizard of O I
was going to say that's that it was as
soon as you said the house G by that's
what I'm seeing power lines were down
there was no way there fires and stuff
are they popping other gas lines around
the neighborhood as well I think that
was the only like big fire and because
it was so wet I can't remember like the
specific but it was something like crazy
like we got and it's pouring rain we got
like 5 Ines of rain in like 15 minutes
it was just torrential downpour but and
is that because of all the um area that
had been burned by the fires is now
there's no tree nothing to stop it so
it's all EX so the fire had burnt up all
the nutrients and roots that would have
held that dirt together and and now it's
just soot and you're getting an ungodly
amount of rain and boom that historic
storm right after historic fire and now
you've got Boulders you know the size of
these mansions that these people are
living in just just tumbling down and
and it was awful we we turned around cuz
the houses were you know where the
street used to be we went back the other
way our my father-in-law's truck got
stuck and and he's offloading his his
Grand his dad and you know getting
family out of that car uh we're trying
to figure out how to fit everyone into
my Kia
sento uh which wasn't a 2018 top safety
pick and
uh we it was scary man it was bet water
was see listen man when you see a house
yeah move past you you realize that we
are no I mean we are ants on this
[__] thing right now you disconnect
house you're just like this is this is
not my life this is a movie this is like
twister that like a barn gone by you
like what yeah it's it seems cinematic
and it and it's your life and it's Pitch
Black it's bright cuz of the fire so the
whole the fires okay but it's 3 in the
morning but the sky is bright cuz of the
fire you can see everything you really
can and it's wild it's just like the
world's largest tiki torch was just
lighting up this neighborhood and cars
yeah once we started driving again you
saw Jeeps getting pushed down by water
and are you seeing other people out as
you're driving
yeah so when um when my my
father-in-law's truck uh father-in-law
now his truck got stuck uh you know my
wife ran up to this house to our left
there was two people getting in a
stretch Escalade uh and and my wife was
like can you please help us like my our
car is stuck my grandparent like my
grandfather is a replaced hip you know
like we we just we need more room and
they just rolled up by the windows and
they're like we're sorry we can't help
you a Str like a limousine escalated no
no like just like two people in a n
seater you know it's it's like they were
just like they would let you yeah
they're sorry we can't help you drove
off and uh there was an older son and
his mom stuck in a Jetta that was like
slowly lift up and like starting to
drift away but they were able to like
get out and just kind of move up the
road to where they weren't stuck so
after I I I shuttled my family I took
turns driving my family in the Kia back
to this guard shack at this neighborhood
that I noticed had power leave some and
go drive up come back Drive o how many
trips Women and Children First Man or
women and cats first and you yeah
exactly I I did have to go back though
that was that was another time where I
was like all right I got the girls to
shelter and I was like I got to go back
and get them what you think about me now
father-in-law there was a little bit I
was like I got
to have pulled a fart up like despite
what you think what yeah so that to us
part
you and me bro uh went back and got him
and his dad and his brother oh damn you
went and got generations for him yeah
and then I went and got back I I went
and got those those strangers that we
didn't know also uh yeah
me you have to I don't I don't think I
would have been okay if if I hadn't and
um we we all ended up going to this
guard shack guard didn't know where to
put us so he took us down to this little
like
uh you know like the snack stand
equivalent of a country club not like a
stand but like the spot that only serves
ice te and crackers not like their nice
restaurant and we're just in this this
room with with are you safe in this room
or you don't know we think we think cuz
it stopped raining not a chance this
mud's going to like bury you guys in
there or it it felt it felt safe uh the
fire was still going because it was
still orange and bright but the rain had
died out so it didn't
feel
like at a certain point the fear stopped
being about the mudslide because it it
just seemed kind of just from in the
short time span of driving around and
seeing where the roads were washed out
you could see like the natural like this
is where water would flow and it didn't
feel like we were in one of those spots
then the fear just became about what's
going on with with these gas lines where
are other gas
leaks and is it going to start raining
again and then do we have to worry again
and we were just in this this Shack with
uh you know uh people that were in their
homes when you know closer of the
explosion that caught fire you burn
victims people that just lost their
houses people that lost more than
houses um and and we just waited there
it was also I don't I talk about this in
a funny way when I run my hour but one
of the things I don't talk about is how
weird it
was to wake up in this like gated
community that had no idea that any of
this had happened cuz all of the debris
flow went completely around like this
one Golf Course community so we were you
know people were waking up to make their
6 a.m. tea time and were just covered in
mud in their country club on couches and
these you know guys are just like are
you members here like why are you on the
furniture here like where where's the
Bag Boy and and you're just like trying
not to scream at him you know or tell
him to go not tip a waitress or
something and it was
weird just this
weird get out kind of vibe once everyone
started waking up and and there were
people that lived in the neighborhood
and you could hear them talking like
well we can't just let them stay here
and and how
quickly and there there were lots of
people trying to help us and there were
lots of people bringing us dry clothes
and and you know they were they were
doing what they can but there was no
water there was no cell towers all the
roads were gone we don't know how long
we're going to be stuck here at one
point the people were literally like
counting water bottles and being like
how do we make this last amongst all
these
people it so
it I can kind of understand like I I
guess why people would be you know
taking priority over other people but it
was I mean such a crash course in how
wonderful and how awful people can be in
in given
circumstances and we weren't you know we
were their neighbors we were you know
these people were in their but their
houses are unaffected so why don't they
just go back to their [__] homes
where they got their food and their
toilet paper and their everything leave
you guys muddy and alone have internet
and they can't be alone so they're all
let's go to the country club and and
talk to everyone else that's in this
shared trauma of us not being able to
get on
Instagram and I'm like because we lost
this [__] lost the house they
lost family membership I don't want to
talk to my family let's go talk yeah
he's got a 7 o'cl tea time he'll be
there God damn yeah staying up late
hanging out with friends yelling at the
game on TV all things I've been doing
over these big weekends so when it's
time to start another big week you
celebrate hydration Monday with liquid
IV we've had liquid IV now for years on
the podcast we keep it at the studio
Kirsten's mom takes it and gives it to
the prisoners all right I don't really
know if it goes to prisoners but it
probably goes to somebody at the
penitentiary one stick plus 16 ounces of
water hydrates better than water alone
it's got three times the electrolytes of
the leading sports drink no artificial
sweeteners eight vitamins and nutrients
plus non GMO and free from gluten dairy
and soy weekends are for going wild have
a game plan for Monday with liquid IV
grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20% off your first order when you
go to liquid i.com and use code honeydew
at checkout that is 20% off your first
order when you shop Superior hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid.com the Honeydew is sponsored by
better help a common misconception about
relationships is that they have to be
easy to be right but sometimes the best
ones happen when both people put in the
work to make them great therapy can be a
place to work through the challenges you
face in all of your relationships
whether it's friends whether it's your
work your significant other or anyone
look you know I believe in therapy I
talk about it all the time I go to
therapy myself um I'd use it whenever I
need it all right you don't have to stay
in it forever that's the other thing you
don't have to be in therapy forever you
go you get some tools you learn about
some things then you get out there in
the real world and you apply them all
right and if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it is designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and then you can
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge become your own
soulmate whether you're looking for one
or not visit betterhelp.com honeydo toay
to get 10% off your first month month
that's betterhelp
hp.com honeydo now let's get back to the
D so how do you get out of there we
waited and uh and the some firefighters
ended up finding us and um and they were
like the US army's coming with Blackhawk
helicopters no that's right that's what
it was Blackhawks they also gave us a
dog this isn't in my ACT either they
gave us a dog it was caked in mud and
and uh this uh other couple that we were
stuck with an older couple my my wife
and my sister-in-law were washing this
dog and getting all the mud off of it
and they were just talking about how
they love dogs so much and and they had
just lost their family dog of 15 years
you know had gotten their kids through
high school college just like a member
of the family Oliver like we just lost
alliver and we miss him so much we love
dogs so much and my sister-in-law was
like well do you want to hold this dog
and they took the dog and they they
wiped the mud off of the collar and the
dog's name was Olive N I swear I was
going to say I was going to make a joke
and say this is Olive cuz it's a black
dog yeah yeah it was a white dog it was
just C oh c them
up and uh no way so now they got Olive
now they got Olive there they weird
beautiful beautiful moment in like this
dark dark event but yeah we ended up uh
getting airlifted out by the uh where
they land in these [__] things just
right on
yeah just it was weird coming that close
to death and then being stuck in like a
pretty beautiful listen if the AR if the
US military is sending black their
Blackhawk helicopters to come it's a
[__] big deal sure or Trump is in
office and these wealthy white people
need to get the [__] off their golf
course yeah like out I don't think
Katrina got the helicopters that quick
and and uh and and I you know I don't
mean to make light of that I spent a lot
of time uh building distribution centers
after that hurricane and and living with
the people there but it it was it was a
big deal over 350 homes were destroyed
how many people died I think 21 and you
said 90% of them were literally on the
street behind you on the street behind
us so that street just got wiped these
people are still sleeping they couldn't
even probably didn't even have a chance
to wake up yeah Buried Alive by mud
became a river that is [__]
terrifying dude and then yeah we got out
then you're this is a weird thing you
then you got all these people what's it
like hold on what's it like to be
sitting on a Blackhawk helicopter with
these people you're flying now where are
they taking you they they took us to a
Red Cross shelter that they had built at
at a nearby airst strip
um it was kind of cool getting on a
Blackhawk helicopter again like I don't
know if you're like this if if I'm in a
hospital and my buddy's sick I start
cracking jokes yeah that's that's what
this whole thing is when life gets dark
you find the light so I mean we we were
scared but we we've been cracking jokes
all day you know we it was awful but it
was like we were sitting around a
campfire and the fact that we got to go
on the helicopter meant that we were
getting out of there meant that you know
man how good that feel it felt amazing
how many people were in one of them with
you like how many people gosh like a doz
in more less I think it was 10 10 yeah
with the two pilots up front yeah 10 so
eight um I don't want to call you
victims but you were victims eight
victims each one survivors well said
yeah uh and and how many helicopters I
don't they were taking turns there was
two helicopters but they were just
shuttling so like they were just cuz how
many people do you think they ended up
rescuing
then at at our little spot I mean just
what you saw
30 maybe more maybe 50 wow cuz everyone
in this neighborhood was like holy [__]
that was the annoying thing too you got
like Bros on their cell phones like get
in the helicopter and it's like you woke
up down the street and walked here and
uh but yeah yeah they they got everyone
out of there I mean these guys are
amazing and You' hear some of these
stories like firefighters would like
they would do search and rescue they
would tie ropes to each other because
they're treading through the mud but you
couldn't tell
if and when there was going to be a
swimming pool uh like drop down and they
would just plummet and think about need
yank him up with a rope
weird weird things uh that I would never
think of and I hope I never have to
think of again and it you ever have
nightmares about that dude I a flying I
I have to the The Roaring and the
inertia of when a plane lands is e
really similar to that just gas fire
rocks
rumbling sound yeah and and I fly every
weekend and nine out of 10 Landings my
my Claw is just like clenching that
armrest just like trying not to be in
that moment and and I talk about this on
stage a lot in a very funny uh funny now
found the light in the dark kind of way
but it it is I get emotional every time
and we we took a family trip to Mexico
this last year and there was a
thunderstorm and why you're flying no
while we were at this this this
Cliffside Resort and lightning must just
just the Thunder I've never felt thunder
like that before but there there are
things where if it wakes me up out of
like a cold sleep I just like my heart
is Off to the Races I am not going back
to sleep weird triggers my wife loves
the rain cuz she's from Seattle mhm
after this like like we have a sensor
light in our bathroom and I remember she
was taking a shower and the sensor light
turned off and all of a sudden she was
in the dark and water was on her and it
was just like just collapsed into a ball
just sobbing in a b just like these are
traumatic traumatic experiences and and
they're awful and you you find the light
what I was getting at before we hopped
into this was how you had that
realization about like oh these people
are waiting in chemo and all of that
when we when I finally got on this train
to get out of Santa
Barbara over oversold for
sure not in a place to be around people
yet and it was amazing getting on this
train and hearing everyone talk about
something I surv survived like something
they put up
with it was just like my kids still
can't go back to school cuz there's no
electricity like I can't get my hair
done because there's no water this one
girl right next to me talking to a
person across from her said my boss is
such a dick I hope he drowns in
dirt and I just remember sitting there
with my headphones in pretending not to
hear all of this and then we Liv through
Co and I would be outside of a grocery
store having a Whole Foods employ me
tell me how much quinoa I can and can't
get and I would be like this is really
[__] annoying and I would just hear
that girl in the back of my head and I I
just think you know we all have trauma
and it's wild to me that we're not
connecting more through it it seems to
be dividing us as a world we're just
like ignoring something that could
really bring us together and and I just
I guess like
uh you know if if you're somebody that
can't just like take a beat to maybe
think about what someone else is going
through uh and take a second to be a
better person empathy little sympathy if
you can't do that little human kindness
then I hope you drown in
[Laughter]
dirt well set yeah was wild I'm man that
is to be airlifted out of anything is a
big [__] deal that's crazy and it's
an and that's just what you dealt with
there's more people that were involved
in that thing it's crazy it was wild I
have yet to have a great experience I
just did some Uso showers in in Japan uh
with Eliza and our troops took us out
and a Blackhawk and toured us over Tokyo
wow yeah it was that had to be badass it
was amazing but even on that flight our
engine gauge failed and and we had to go
back so I'm still like 0 for two too on
on helicopter rides but uh those guys
are pros and I I actually wasn't it was
cool hearing them talk and like reverse
engineer the entire aircraft by reading
every other gauge to just know that like
ah gauge is just broken nothing's
actually wrong with the plane it's just
but you got to go back damn that'd be
badass though that is wild it it was a
wild way to see that City yeah yeah and
such a cool I'd never done anything like
that being able to perform for our
troops and and just really get like a a
working knowledge of of that part of the
world and that way of life that was wild
um did your father-in-law ever [__]
be like thanks for coming back and
getting me still think you're a piece of
ship there was uh there was a moment
with the helicopters where we didn't
know how many there were going to be how
many trips were going to be taken and
and he like did come up to me and he's
like you take my parents and my
daughters like we're staying here and
that that to me seemed like a
very uh
you know shake of hands also real
quick theyve for years had never seen me
do standup comedy we did a show in Santa
Barbara two years after the mudslide oh
wow and it was going to be their first
time seeing me do standup my wife
couldn't be there she was at a
bachelorette party and I took Eliza over
to her over to my in-laws uh or soon to
be in-laws at the time and uh the whole
time Ron was like Eliza how do you like
your job and Eliza said something along
the lines of like I love it you know you
put a lot into the art and I hope people
connect with it and my father-in-law
just started going you think it's art
and just started this Devil's Advocate
standup is an art it became very clear
very quickly it had nothing to do with
Eliza and everything to do with me about
to marry his daughter but everything was
like stand up is an art and I was like
how is it an art art he's like it's not
art until you can make a living doing it
and I was like okay what about Picasso
he's like not an artist and I was like
your daughters they would bring you home
macaroni art you put it on the the
refrigerator definitely not art and and
he kept coming home to uh you're not an
artist until you can make a living doing
it and we went to the show and uh
ashen's little sister who was then 16 or
15 at the time side stage I tell this
mudslide story I'm I'm scared I almost
don't tell it Eliza like slaps me in a
closet was like this is your story you
got to tell it and it's maybe like my
favorite set I've ever had I've
never I I cried in like a deeper way
than I usually cry when I tell the story
and I got off stage Eliza's husband was
tearing up he's like I don't think I've
ever heard an audience laugh
cathartically before and it was just a
lot of those people out there went
through this with you yeah yeah and it
was it was that it was it was healing it
was the I've told this all over the
world I got goosebumps now but it it did
feel like
you guys are going to get 100% of this
and you're going to laugh cuz you're
broken the same way that I'm broken and
and you know that this is coming from
Love and not from hate and it was just
one of the most rewarding moments in my
standup career and I remember my in-laws
just kind of getting out of there before
meet and greet and everything I didn't
really get to catch up with them after
the show but I I texted my my sister
in-law I was like did your did your dad
say anything on the way home and he said
yeah he got in the car closed the door
and all he said the whole ride home was
he's going to make a living doing this
and I was like okay all right I got
Goosebumps all right still not art but
he's going to make a Liv and do
it with that generation I'll take it
listen here's the other thing I laugh
about this all the time because forget
about everything else that generation of
men were Vietnam Korean War and then
here we are going I want to act and tell
jokes and like what the [__] are you
talking about and then we throw art on
top we like that's not [__] art like
this guy had a machine gun in his you
know what I mean like they're a
different breed of men they're like you
want to do what my father fought in
World War II I brother yeah you want to
go dance what the [__] are you talking
about my my buddy Bill Dixon had a joke
where he's like the totality of my
grandfather and Father's experience is
now something we play in video games
like my dad losing his best friend is
now summarized
into like that's it just a vibrating
control
and and yeah I I I can't speak to to
their struggles or anything like that
and and I I know I'm Cut From a
Different Cloth and and obviously I I
think I'm more sensitive than than a lot
of guys but that that that night was a
big win for me and [__] yeah good for
you that was wild yeah um I do want to
talk about one more thing if you're
comfortable talking about it I know
you're um you had said your stepfather
past and I know from the the crab Feast
your stepfather was not really a fan of
yours you were not really a fan of his
um but he died when how long ago I think
he passed um two two years ago was he
still with your mom no they they had
divorced for a while um yeah I I think I
talked about it in another podcast just
kind
of how we didn't have a great
relationship just kind of piggybacking
off of what we were just talking about
just generational differences you know I
came growing being raised by like my my
mother and father was told be whoever
you want do whatever you want to do and
and he had a more dated mentality of
like this is what a man is this is how
you do it and and we just didn't didn't
really see eye to eye it was pretty
traumatic um and yeah he passed away
recently um and it is uh was he still in
your life like did you would you see him
how long had it been since you'd seen
him he he was in my life because he's my
little brother's father got it okay
which is a complicated relationship I
love my brother so much I don't get to
see him that much and and cuz we're
we're 14 years apart
um and I knew that his relationship with
his dad was never going to be the
relationship I had with my dad right uh
and I'm not going to spend my I my
parents got divorced I've heard my mom
say [__] about my dad I've heard my dad
say [__] about my mom I'm never going to
be the person that says anything in in
poor taste about anyone significant
other like you you know that is I'm not
here to poison that
well and so he wasn't in in my life and
and I worked really kind of hard to do
that you know I I family's really
important to me at one point I sold my
car so I could help my mom afford a
condo cuz she couldn't afford to get
divorced and that KIA sento bro n it was
a that got eating up in the Grand Prix I
Grand Prix bro not the cool one not like
the one that wanted to be a sedan with
wrong branding on it uh you know he he
was in my life and it was it was weird
he ended up getting dementia and
um I I don't I worry a lot right now
about being a good dad and uh if I'm
being way too honest I think my biggest
fear right now is just not being
enough and that's something I want to
start writing about more
but just we how often we confuse being
enough with having everything and just
wanting everything to be perfect
but I I thought about
him as a dad and and how we
never got along but I I would like to
think that he was trying to prepare me
for the world that he thought still
existed but I was just so hurt that I i'
pushed him away and and then then he got
dementia and
then you
know you lose you lose these moments to
even kind of have a a healing
conversation you know by the time I saw
him again I saw him at my my brother's
High School
graduation and and this was before he
was like in any kind of like care or
anything but he didn't know who I was
and and I lived with him how did he not
is he cuz he was going at that point was
that's the beginning of it you're
thinking about I see and I didn't know
he didn't know who I was right he he was
telling me stories about how he used to
work in radio and and you're like and I
was like yeah you've told me this one
before and he go oh yeah yeah and then
at one point towards the end of the
ceremony he he leaned into my my older
step brother's ear and was just like who
is this guy and and that was that was
wild just kind of learn learning that
like this this person that you're mad at
and For Better or Worse has shaped you
isn't there anymore that doesn't even
think of you you're not even you're not
even a thought going through that
computer yeah and here you are holding
all this so much yeah and and how much
of that has slowing me down how much of
that has shaped other relationships with
men that I have uh other people in
general and and I've have spent time
being angry and this person isn't there
anymore
and and what was left of him was good
like you know it was I was like this is
a nice guy if I met this guy
now I I think we'd get along really well
and then you start to
remember the the good things and and you
know when he was there for you when he
would try to be there for
you and it was just
a a moment where life just like forces a
lesson on you in an instant and uh you
know again we I I went to kind of s I
didn't know I was saying goodbye but I
went to see him in in this uh Care
Facility where he was and
just no idea who I was but we brought
him a root beer from Carl's Jr and I
don't think I've ever seen a human being
be that
excited about anything he was just like
just smiling with the teeth he had left
just like so sincerely wholefully
grateful for just a corn syrup beverage
and and I was trying to tell him that I
was about to become a dad and he thought
I worked there and my mom was mad you
know my mom had been neged by this guy
for 15 years he doesn't have half the
teeth in his mouth and stos she's like
we were
married it was just it was just wild
just seeing uh seeing all of that anger
just have nowhere to go yeah and for
feeling silly for holding on for it for
so long and then just being ashamed that
I could lose someone like that and
really
not I'm not proud of this I know how
brutal this sentence sounds and and
maybe someday this will change but when
he passed I didn't feel
I all I felt was I am so sad for my
younger brother and I felt bad that I
didn't know how to be there for him
because I haven't lost a parent but I I
didn't feel like I had lost anything and
and that no you gained something
actually I mean if you really think
about it I think you said your goodbye
when you needed to say goodbye and you
realize that this person's not even this
person and that anger and all that um
old school mentality whatever you want
to call it's gone so before that
entity leaves that carcass you'd already
you'd already made your peace and I
don't think you need to feel a certain
way about this person passing I think
the right feeling is hey man my my
brother's father's gone but that's not
your
father at some point your mom's going to
pass and that's when you'll have that
moment with your brother because you
share that parent I don't think you're a
bad person
for not feeling a certain way about it I
get it but you already you already made
your peace and you felt your way about
it the good thing is you're not over
here like I'm so glad that [__]
I hope he dies what what she say drowned
by mud or you're not feeling that
[__] way about this person you know
what I mean so I don't think it means
you're a bad person but I get the
conflict of like I don't really feel a
certain way that this person's gone yeah
I felt like part of me was broken like
like it it should have it should have
rocked me a little bit more and and
thank you for saying that man I
genuinely don't think it should have I
feel like I'm getting my money's worth
I'm saving some money on therapy but
also it did Rock You it rocked you for
years it bothered the [__] out of you it
affected you for years and now you
realize prior to that final moment of
him expiring that what a waste all of
this was for him for you he's not you're
not even in that computer as I said
anymore and he's still in yours yeah and
he's still in your emotions and your
stomach in your head that real estate
was his R God non stop and you're not
even he you're not even on his Planet
yeah on his Planet so I think um I don't
think you're a bad person for that I
think it went the way it should and
again you're not over here like good I'm
glad you know none of that none of that
I could never be you felt what you
needed to feel and then you felt like oh
[__] what a waste what a what a waste of
time that was yeah yeah there it
is not not uh you know the everything's
kind of divided and and it I guess it
helped me realize that like
uh I guess I'll use Politics as an easy
example obviously this could be very
volatile very quickly but I I'm not
you're doing so good you were doing
so going to torpedo it just cuts to
color
Stripes we've never had them but I want
to put them
in it's it's very easy to look at uh
anyone and that doesn't think or act the
same way as you and be like how could
you ever how could you ever but I and
and that was my relationship with my
stepdad like I did not understand his
way of thinking I and his with you right
but I would never question the way that
my brothers felt about him and and what
he could mean to other people and uh I
think that's also one of my favorite
Parts about just being a comedian is
just having like a working knowledge of
our country and just being like yeah
that they should vote differently there
their their their life is different but
being able to travel enough and and
interact with everyone of us we travel
this country enough to see when you go
somewhere if you're a real person you
get in meshed in that you're like I I
understand why you make the decisions
you make I see what you mean yeah of
course and I don't have to agree but
you're my neighbor I love you and and I
get it your whole neighborhood behind
you die you better love these
[__] neighbors [__] I also
think a part of it is and the big part
and you've said it several times is you
want to be a good father so you had a
stepfather that was n great so it's
another thing you're trying to correct
and break a cycle so you're good bro
you're good you went back and got
[__] strangers out of a mudslide in a
Kia sento you're good two wheel drive
not a [__] Humvee a goddamn two all
no two front wheeel drive it it had a
sport
mode people dude you're good bro yeah
and this episode was great thank you
thank you for coming on here and being
vulnerable and talking about all this
anytime thank you for having me you're
welcome dude one more time promote
everything you'd like to promote please
uh oh wait I got to ask I forgot to ask
you almost um advice you'd give to your
16-year-old self so now after everything
we've talked about today going back to
stepfathers and mudslides and being a
dad and what advice would you give to
your 16-year-old
self might be a a long-winded answer but
uh
my grandfather passed away he was like
uh my hero my my mom's dad and uh years
later my mom found a letter he had
written to me when I was in Middle
School kind of like struggling with
these things with my stepdad and I was a
theater nerd everyone want to be a
quarterback and my grandfather and
grandmother wrote me this letter just
telling me as adults that every other
adult in my life was wrong wow and that
I could I could do it and that I should
do it and it's an unrealistic want to
you know want to be in theater or do
standup or whatever but if you work hard
and humbly enough that you know uh your
work can speak for itself and you don't
have to be loud about it or anything and
I I think if I could go back and talk to
my 16-year-old self it would be like
yeah just listen to that letter and know
know that that is 100% accurate cuz I I
I think I'm doing a great job but I I
get frustrated when I think about like
man
if I if I would have started two years
earlier or just been like a little less
scared of shaking hands and like putting
myself out there where I'd be or you
could have died in a Mudslide and not
even had any of this bro that's right so
that's the other way so just yes you can
yes you can just do it yeah yeah um
thank you again sorry plug and promote
everything please my bad uh my name is
Hunter Hill and I'm touring the country
you can find me at hunterhill comedy.com
and hunterhill comedy on Instagram and
thank you dude hell yeah such a
privilege thank you bro um as always
Ryan sickler on all social media come
see me on tour get your tickets on my
website at ransler
[Music]
[Applause]
oh